cientos de cuerpos son incinerados
masivamente los crematorios no dan
abasto ante la avalancha de muertes por
kobe 19 en india muchos de los
familiares lamentan no haber tenido un
último contacto con sus seres queridos y
critican la asistencia médica limitada
y hasta ayer estaba sentada afuera del
hospital y me decían que mi esposo
estaba bien les pedí que me dejaran
verlo por última vez e incluso les
ofreció dinero para que me dejaran estar
con él ahora está muerto estoy tan
molesta no hay nada que yo pueda hacer
[Música]
la emergencia sanitaria también se
siente con la falta de oxígeno la oleada
de contagios en india ha hecho que
encontrar y llevar suministros a los
enfermos sea todo un reto fuera de la
tienda más de un centenar de personas ha
hecho fila con la esperanza de que que
es suficiente para llenar sus botellas
mobile es para mi tío tiene 75 años de
una condición crítica comparativa antes
de la oleada de covite el propietario de
la tienda vendió oxígeno líquido a
empresas de construcción pero eso era
antes gambaria en este momento realmente
no es suficiente sólo tengo suficiente
para la mitad de las solicitudes los
hospitales están desbordados en todo el
país algunos reaccionan lo que les queda
bajando los niveles de los respiradores
el gobierno dice que puede producir 7
mil 200 toneladas al día pero la
necesidad diaria con el coronavirus es
de 8 mil toneladas india tiene reservas
de 55 mil toneladas pero la distribución
sigue siendo un reto varios países como
españa reino unido y francia anunciaron
que proporcionarán tres fábricas de
oxígeno móviles capaces de producir
1.500 litros de oxígeno por
nueva delhi ha intentado tranquilizar a
la población diciendo que pronto
llegarán más suministros médicos y más
ayuda internacional